Володимир Борисович Гройсман
c політик нового покоління
прем'єр-міністр гройсман ще одна фігура
президента порошенка на політичному шах
їм знайти україни
глава держави ви буду ви ивл одну
вертикаль pcb загину готовий акція
свого часу ра було його по фартух і
viktor yanukovych це леонід кучма так
важливо аналітик берлінського беру
європейської ради з міжнародних
фітнес густав гриз аль дин виріз в
системі явин багатий чому ви хрестові
store методи довіряю лише близьким
людям виду я наводжу переговорів за вас
тонким і не хоче даєте до публічний
людей і нам а гаїті раніше за 6 ти свої
акти vanish змінить україни все чекаю
реакції політики в те воно пак стрима
на офіційний берлін дуже до і вигляд
нового українського кабміну миха інших
реформ курс на реформи за раз треба
нагайна продовжить і україна не може
лікаря відразу
стабільний то ефективний і ряди 0
ви вирішували продумую для активної боротьби
з корупцією
червоні тут мене подалі фріформ україні
за подальші реформи в Україні to provide
на вигляд ця муть судами save таланти доу
ряду переднього складу влада
намазалася int та крилатий про креми нових
реформаторі у технократів за крима так
званих іноземних легіонерів проти
новому кабміні ви вирішили вбити і seabass
міністри іноземців
ми назавжди до овалу застудися
іноземців на позиціях гуріді
думаю в Україні до 100 книг вольфіка ван
їхніх людей віку можете срубати і їжі на
проблем ще можна ван його скачає так
звіду а павла давали архів занадто
великого розділу як ішли і обожнювання ти
намалюю реформи при значенні на посади
знайомих такий рубці традицій не допоміг і
українського карим листя про т у чикаго
не з usb листя видно нижнього
президента України після паді ледве
річкові долини на майдані
значно вище ікри тако буде значно жертв
і шию